and about 30 000
here in the ballpark today as we get set
for brewers and
rockies baseball corbin burns you got to
love him you look at his hair and you're
like this guy knows what he's doing
big cutter guy throws really hard likes
to attack the zone
a swing at a miss burns picks up
strikeout
number one one two on the way a swing
enemies
gets the strikeout two k's in the end a
good start for corbin burns
so it'll be the 13th start for john gray
and he's looking for career win number
50. and he got him on a slider so a
great start
for gray as he punches out colton wong
and see later at 97. you just see it man
he's kind of strutting around that mound
he feels good
and he's gone on a slider could you have
a better first inning in john gray's
return
i think not three hitters three
strikeouts
you see the shift is on for the lefty
narvaez which is interesting too because
he's
so willing to hit a little blue out in
the left field
and he just punches one to the opposite
field
he's thinking too he takes a big turn
tapia got to it quickly
how about that right on cue tim good
analysis partner here's willy adams
already becoming a fan favorite here in
milwaukee
and a hard hit ball into right center
narvaez
will turn and head to third and the
brewers going with the humble approach
here in this second inning
a couple of opposite field hits first
and third with one way and the claws are
out early
and he got a strikeout which is huge two
outs
bounced to third great pickup by mcmahon
he made that look really easy one and
one to count
gray gets up on down hira goes to second
out there
adamus throne it's picked out at first
oh man what a play
i think he's safe all that all that for
that very good play by here the headsets
are off and safe at first will be the
call and
just as we thought might happen 2-2
pitch and a swing out of this
chambia that chambia right there throws
a beauty there and then on the first
pitch a little broken back grounder
out to wong who makes a play to win the
inning burns leading off here the brewer
pitcher
burns with a base hit and the brewer
pitcher comes up
with a knock his fifth hit of the year
slider strike three so juan is the
strikeout victim that's
five now for gray one ball one strike
griez down base hit
burns to second luisa
swung on and missed foul tip caught by
diaz
and yelich is out number two and that is
the sixth
strikeout for greg you have christian
yelling 3-1 you throw a backdoor slider
and he come back adam 3-2 and throw
another dirty slider
the bottom just falls out of it two on
again one out in this hitting now
there's two outs and now there's three
outs
john with 97 mile an hour gas
seven strikeouts already
up and in would expose and there's down
and away get the punch out of nervaius
that's eight
howls for the gray wolf today
the eight strikeouts for john matches a
season high on may 4th
he struck out eight giants in six
innings
oh my how about that slider that any
good strikeout number nine for the gray
wolf
burns sinigang five strikeouts he deals
on the ground a hot one nice pick urias
and the throw is good luis arias with a
beautiful play
on a wicked hop he was ready got the
little shimmy bounce beforehand backhand
come up check it out
didn't have a whole lot of time to think
about anything but throwing it across
the diamond
swinging dance three pitches strikeout
number 10
for gray so now he matches pedro estacio
for most double-digit strikeout
performances
in their uh respective careers with 15.
back to the top of the order third time
through old wong
wong hits it sharply to the left hoppy
was shallow
can't make the play off the wall it goes
called log into second with a double
long off second and this is popped up
and playable i believe for cronin and
foul brown
good job by jonathan
this is slowly hit to third that'll be
an infield hit the crowd will groan and
grasp and urias feels bad about it
but that's also a typical toppy ahead al
they're standing for corbin burns
through five and a third onono
topia takes off and the throw
not gonna get him not even close round
number three for dazza against burns
this ball put in play with authority
there's a single topic is going to get a
green light from stu cole
and the throw from yelich is cut off
throw to second
safe there one nothing colorado that
connection once again
of tapia and daza
charlie bounces this one toward the
middle of the diamond and he's gonna
beat that
blackman goes and it's a cold strike
three
two two hits it hard through the middle
of the diamond another base hit for
brendan
with one out needs it first for elias
diaz
and rogers good read spilly let's talk
about
read the dirt ball read the uh the angle
of the baseball out of the pitcher's
hand
brennan rogers as soon as that ball was
down he before it hit the dirt he was
moving
well there's a base hit to left and stu
cole
is gonna set rogers throw to the plate
cut off again
two to nothing so diaz coming through
with a huge
seventh inning hit two nothing colorado
here's fuentes to pinch hit
and he gets into this one deep left and
that's the way to do it
pitch it two-run home run joshua fuentes
and now the rockies are enjoying a ford
to nothing advantage in milwaukee
good for fuentes his sixth of the year
we have it here in milwaukee jam shot
lazy little fly ball
garcia's there and sanchez has his home
debut
and here's hira that ball's hammered
he'll send one way out of here oh
long home run and the brewers are on the
board as keston hira goes deep
a very welcome sign right there for
casting hero
indeed he was all over that ball they're
okay with saying you know i'm gonna take
a solo home run long has been known to
do it
well right center long sends it
out of here colton wong
solo home run and it's a two-run game in
milwaukee in the eighth
these are high-profile situations that
you need to get out of
swing and a miss another strikeout for
cousins give him three
and four batters faced two outs in the
ninth and a swing and a miss he got him
jake cousins has faced 14 batters in the
big leagues
in two games nine strikeouts
in two played appearances this will be
the 22nd
pitch that nervaez has seen from daniel
bart
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's outside the board won that
first battle norvaez wins this one and
now you have the tying rod cone to the
plate
in willia davis one ball no strikes on
adamus
swing and a drive deep left field
willie adamus strikes again
against the colorado rockies and the
brewers
come back down
four nothing two run for
william thomas two-two pitch
on the ground around third he's gonna
hold right there
black with a very accurate arm that's a
smart move by jason lane
and he misses on four straight
now the bases are loaded and if there
was anybody due for a moment like this
tim it is kesten hero
hiro that's a shot it is caught here
comes
pina throw to the plate manny's in
and that's the ball game the brewers win
casting hira with a sacrifice fly
and the brewers walk off the rockies on
a friday night